quand même j'ai mis du temps du
président mois
ensuite je suis allé sans aucun dommage
sur nouvelobs est une architecture
j'ai dû vieux j'ai pu voir en peinture
je me suis adressé au temps
mais surtout je me suis intéressé aux
conditions d'habitat et au logement
justement j'ai fait de relogement que j
avais je me suis rendu compte que ma
route à strasbourg il ya eu une grosse
machine un gros plein travail
disons pour le chômage alors que à
barcelone dans ma chambre y arriver
là.je du betty mimaud des mélodies appel
à la climatisation en main sur un billet
ici qui a toujours toujours la
climatisation et les grands managers
d'appareils plusieurs appareils dans
selon l'élu la réponse humaine aux
besoins du groupe s'est amarré le toit
du bâtiment à usage qu'ils les lâchent
public collectif mais aussi normes les
bâtiments leur stand les maximums uss
cole dans le cornulier
c'est donc le grand jour arrive et que
leur utilisation par el correo
donc le comprends c'est l'indépendance
qui vivent toujours changer l'europe
d'une manière consciente ou inconsciente
ce soit le climat continental à
strasbourg ce soit le climat
méditerranéen à la seule ce soir là les
désactiver ok on a toujours cherché mon
bord nous on bloque le monde il ya ce
afin qu'il est sur le banc avec l'usagé
quotidien aura des plus gores
on peut simplement dire que c'est
d'avoir une soupe en est et livrant une
augmentation du niveau des mers
mais la question qui ont compensé par
quelque chose d'intéressant
ça a été toujours le travail d'archivés
ils ont toujours penser aux emplois dans
le radio crochet confort la cellule
parisien dans les camps dit
il ya les anciennes mosquées que pendant
entre l'intérieur en hommage aux grandes
chaleurs
je félicite donc le bon plan les
attraits dans les gens concilier
développement ces mosquées
il force du mensonge de l'emploi grâce à
des techniques basées sur l'expérience
acquise à travers les années donc c'est
du réel parce que ces prêts sur
l'expérimentation en grande désillusion
solution jusqu'à la situation idéale
mais alors j'aurais pu le faire il faut
plus construire tout la vision du
bâtiment pourra se passe comment
lien qui maintient aujourd'hui on change
la société voulu on veut servir les
données avant lundi pour de servir le
président digitale pourpre et vont
lentement on va pouvoir diviser tout
petit ventre arrondi et donc avoir une
idée de ce à quoi il ressemble c'est ce
vers quoi il est nommé sur le comex sur
la situation climatique y donnait aussi
l'emploi on doit évoluer mais aussi dans
la vie donnée sur la dépendance
l'espace et les caractéristiques la
réalité tout ça prend un fort virage
gaubert qui donne à la réalité sans
entrain bâtiment est ce que vous vous
rendez vous la différence entre le
modèle d'abord inspiré est à présent de
prendre en compte les réflexions qui
seront dans l'action et le monde hésite
et qui consiste à prévoir à modéliser
avant même d'avoir construit d'arrivants
la grande complicité
a strasbourg y avait des problèmes
qu'autre chose
ces âmes celle acquérir des appareils de
chauffage la climatisation à ce sport
tas qui lie à la finalisation avec 6,6
au bf c'est parce qu' on cherche donc
pas à ce travail le travail de
conception préalables à la construction
l'inconvénient de ne pas avoir prévu une
avance de base comment modéliser les
ultimes secondes mais l'on sait que le
salut est dans une telle situation au
rendement pas mais dans les situations
on consomme beaucoup d'énergie dans les
situations où salut prédiction d'un
vecteur d'énergie l'électricité et mais
aussi son environnement sa a désiré sur
les changements climatiques sur la
couche d'ozone et cédé un double
avantage de la conception à tripoli qui
nous permet d'arriver au bon peuple tout
en pensant uniquement de l'électricité
ou d'énergie mais qu'est ce que c'est
bon port le long point sur cette notion
et jason witten cbo
mais lui il avait les études
arrive alors si tu trouves pas que leurs
vêtements et dans ses études et qui
s'est passé sur une réaction sur un
équilibre entre une énergie et l'aja n'a
pu encore humains c'est une engeance
donc il a le bon goût est l'équation dix
ans de ligue 2 l'équipe et du plongeon
ces travaux de monsieur bon démarrage
entités internationales des entités
internationales iso journée les andalous
narration ibérique ce que pour voir
l'intérieur du bâtiment
jan hoogendoorn à l'abandon c'est en
allemagne qu'il écrit moment
malheureusement les derniers
c'est le fameux iso et générant celui ça
des repousses documents qui décrivent
encore et toujours on va se battre sur
ça pour définir leur propre dans notre
modélisation essayer de documents
présentent ces conditions vous pouvez
consulter ces documents s'ils voulaient
prolonger des débats et il est très
limité pour résumer on va pas vous dire
combien de confort qui a perdu leur
emploi
sara lee selon plusieurs facteurs mais
c'est toujours entre 20 et 25 degrés
ensuite il ya une humilité et lui laisse
blanc a dévoilé la maison c'est à la
situation de grand beau et c'est cette
violence les north atlantic est en
revanche toujours en deux matches on en
a les plaies de l'accusation lourd dans
la fin à l'un des otages donc on verra
du technique a dit il
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça qu'on sent
énergie pour l'un et le confort ça sert
l'opposé avec la situation
ainsi ce qui est en situation active
c'est le confort on arrive à dominique
avon cobourne
l'idée c'est d'abord pour la lexus donc
les députés ni passif comme quoi en
prouver six avions du soleil ajouté on
oublie certainement d'une ventilation
naturelle ou au nord kivu faisant des
lieux qui isole négligence est très
importante
le mur de notre action n'est pas isolé
parce que ça nous permet de nous tenter
chine achète en équipe de montréal la
maison lisandro lopez chypre en hiver
quand on joue à la drh a nargué les
sorties à l'extérieur ce lieu qui isole
l'a été elle est vraiment léger et les
purs d'un seul centimètre s'exhale va
aller où ses amis de l'épisode il a vu
il avait l'épaisseur circule entre les
deux mais nous voulons donc il faut pas
lâcher
il faut que la sauce ils évoluent il
faut que dans nos maisons
ils vous font chier sous leur maison
il faut en rien sa performance
énergétique
il faut dire
maison à haut niveau je veux luc besson
qui est passible d'une maison qui fait
entre protéique facile puisque les
techniques active qu'elle ait jamais été
ça veut dire que la raison l amour
emporte tout en observant des derricks
pas si on reprend tout mon énergie
alors là c'est un peu nombreux faut pas
lâcher
il faut aller donc associés pour lui il
faut que les gens sachent en achetant
une maison une maison qui les nomme
niveau les hommes qui n'aimaient pas
confortable même si elle est moins chère
on va payer la différence de prix on va
récupérer parce qu'on va payer les
installations qui vont faire du volume
en outre par ailleurs mouvement on va
payer les factures d'électricité mais
aussi on a plié
il ya des spécialistes nous sommes levés
aux architectes à sanaa qu'il y avait
des travaux
il a voulu que l'accident construit en
matériaux divers
ces bâtiments il a invoqué le confort y
avait des gros nuls la barrage allant du
sud l'egypte ça fonctionnait très bien
mais quel succès les bourthois pas sur
la société pas préparé cette solution la
solution qui avouent leurs discussions
du passé plus indépendant et d'une
architecture matériaux lourds qui sont
qui semble pas adéquat pour remercier la
solution la solution ça se bat à les
reprendre et des mimiques fait d'une
manière chronique cc marmande et ancien
minutes comme les mosquées site et non
ce serait plutôt de fournir une solution
qui va tenir une maison conçue à l'aller
logiciel une maison qu'elle utilise
straw ils les ont qui a le monopole avec
une eau de consommation d'énergie et en
servant au maximum et équitation
il faut que tout le monde sache que
c'est dans l'intérêt des raisons nous
passons le plan de notre temps moi par
exemple dans la région les objets à
quitter je veux m'en fais toujours des
moments où l'usiné par les femmes je
m'appelle de mort au cas où j'avais bien
beau mais warren des mauges avait jamais
eu peu de soleil peine de mort aux
généraux montmagny jean-guy moreau
j'étais seul devoir être quand je suis
revenu je met en lumière les jours je
suis parti c'est donc dans la maison que
ça se passe dans les parcs de souvenirs
ici on y pense bien
on a beau souvenir dans dix ans le plus
grand talent
pensez-y augmenté
de plus les espaces avec un rendement
terni ce sont les espaces qui permet des
interactions humaines qui donc gêné il
faut penser à la maison contre une chose
de très vivant dans une maison ça
respire ça transpire s'allier avec son
app store une maison une maison
martineau 13 gogh la tige de jeunes
hommes dans leur maison est votre plus
grand monde
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]